okay so here's the interesting thing
about this show is that no matter what
you have to draw comparisons to the last
show Avatar The Last Airbender now with
that said I still think this is a good
show I like this show but I am seeing
this major problem the major problem is
that avatar found a way to very well mix
this continuing story with other stories
that seemed episodic but could still
also tie everything back in together and
the reason this jumps to mind is in this
episode I realized if I had to hear one
more time you know there's only so much
you can chase after a mod why don't you
relax for a bit I am going to punch
someone cuz it's like no there's not
enough chasing of them on go after a mod
you have this cool awesome villain and I
want to see more of him I want to see
more conflicts with him but you see him
for an episode and that's like you're
gonna go two or three episodes pretty
much without him and in Avatar you could
get away with that because you were
constantly moving you were constantly in
a new location there was something else
that these characters could discover
either again different location or about
themselves and maybe this is another
interesting problem about this show is
that a lot of people say well cause a
lot more adult I don't know if that's
totally true elements are much more
adult other elements are much more
childish and what I mean by that is that
you have the actual story or the issues
that they're dealing with I should say
are more adult what was avatar that was
evil bad guys trying to take over the
world I yes that has happened in past
history but we've seen this quite a bit
and every kick understand bad guy trying
to take over the world got it this is
about people who are born with this
advantage
and whether or not that's making this
social economical world work or if it's
throwing it out of balance and so far I
mean what what kid is gonna understand
that so on the one hand I get it and
it's sort of like the x-men thing you
know is this a legit argument or not and
it's sometimes it is sometimes it isn't
and it's it's very very adult on the
other hand the developments the
characters are going through are so I
know why even wants a kid show it's so
high school and yeah they're I know
they're teenagers I got it
but okay draw reference to another show
Oh Daria handle handled teenage problems
and stuff that happened in high school
much better than this show did uh which
is not to say this show is handling it
horribly it's really not it's that
compared to the last show we had and how
high they raised the bar and seeing how
the rest of the show is trying to be
very very adult this serves as very
distracting um and these are not really
bad characters either you can identify
with them but these problems that
they're making and these conclusion that
you're the conclusions are okay but the
the problems they're coming across are
far too familiar for a show that's
trying to do something really really
different and it seems like it's falling
too much I'm sorry these very common
story arts that that you see a lot
especially in kids programming um with
that said it's just talking about like
you know God why don't you show a mom
you know more and more we have the
aftermath which of course doesn't really
have much of Amman in it uh but it is
starting to get the story going a little
bit but again just when you think that
love triangle stuff is done
they keep hinting we're not done yet you
still get a little prettier little
petunia T little otra
there you go still there still there
it's just oh so so so that's annoying
but this episode does get to something
which I like it and it does come on to
this development that you could kind of
see coming outsourcing like okay either
the daughter or the father is a villain
you know it has to be one or the other
and turns out the father um and you get
some cool machines at the ends are these
bioshock machines actually they look
like the final boss in the Simpsons
arcade game for like the people that
remember that is they even down to the
old guy inside pushing the button so
that's pretty cool
I'm you get chemical action sequence
with it um you get your Darth Vader
moment of the father going to the
daughters there you join me I'll never
join you
dude take that dad um so okay so we have
this new uh deal with the word I'm
looking for
this new teammate I'm bored essentially
um and that's cool
and it looks like um uh why am I
forgetting your name Tom's daughter
should just keep going or that um okay
next time uh but it looks like you know
she's now going rogue it wants to stop
Amon on her own terms and so forth and
you know great but at the same time you
kind of feel like you know come on let's
get to you know let's actually get to
the meaty stuff here every time you
watch it it's like amber a little closer
we'll look closer
no let's just go and I think if it did a
better job distracting me from that from
the fact that this is going slow because
by god this only has twelve episodes
avatar went very slow when you really
think about it they would drop little
bits of information but there's lots of
filler episodes here and there but you
are so enjoying the characters that
didn't matter and these characters I me
up Makos start off interesting but now
it's just sort of bland nice guy and
that's not as much fun uh the daughter
the churro for guy you know could get
interesting if they have fun with the
fact that she had to whatever betray her
father and leave him behind you know
maybe we can do something like that or
maybe she's a traitor
that'd be cool like it was all just a
big show that that seems unlikely but
let it be a cool twist anyway um the the
other guy Mako's um brother just sort of
seems like Sokka white you know
sometimes you'll get a laugh
that's just sir like oh that's just
we're watching Sokka okay um and Korra
again at points I'm like yeah I really
get her I really understand and they
capture that frustration but at other
times you just sort smack your head and
say okay I know the lesson you're going
can we you know can you do something
more interesting with it uh and that's
or what I felt with this it felt like
for every every little bit you move
forward with the story you're sort of
pushing it a touch back with this
recycled stuff that we see in another
shows and in most TV shows I'm okay with
that because it's just become the status
quo you know it's how I put it okay
it's like the comic strip BC you know
the cavemen it's like is that really
horrible no is it really fantastic and
that really just sort of is what it is
compared to Calvin and Hobbes it's like
holy no comic strip is as good as
Calvin and Hobbes it's like what the
hell is this guy doing
what are you guys doing you other comic
strips you're out there I've been
reading your stuff when Calvin and
Hobbes was here it's like that now
imagine the guy did Calvin Hobbes does a
sequel to Calvin house like how the
Hobbes grown up I heard there's a comic
of that doesn't does exist it's not by
the guy did count my husband died Gress
uh let's say this exists and it only has
maybe half what the original Calvin and
Hobbes had and it's different and that's
fine but it's sir falling into these
other cliches that those other comic
strips did there's something a little
lacking in that and and that's a little
bit of a shame but at the same time
think that there's anything these
creators have shown me it's that wait
till you get all the way through and see
where it goes and and that is what I
want to do and I do want to see what
happens so I guess I didn't go into
great detail about the specifics of this
episode because again it's not like a
bad episode I mean that nothing's like
bad you know it's it's just not as good
when you compare it to avatar and I know
it's not supposed to be that good but at
the same time if you're looking to make
something better and just make it the
best that you can I would say that the
way to do it is just serve take back
some of these other uh some of these
other arcs in these storylines that
we've seen a million times in other kid
shows unless you're gonna do something
new with them and nothing bad new is
really than done uh yet you know again
maybe they will you know something
all the people commenting always say
it's like you know wait wait you're
gonna see what happens wob applause so
as it is now for me it's sort of like
watching a better version of Harry
Potter uh because Harry Potter I know I
said I made a comparison before and but
it is sort of the same thing it's like
every time you're moving the story
little bits like you got these character
archetypes are like seeing them seeing
them that although I think these
characters more interesting Harry Potter
personally I think this world is more
interesting Harry Potter that's why I
say more interesting Harry Potter uh but
it's sort of the same problem it's going
very slowly and sir falling into these
other tropes that it doesn't need to
fall into it's not required um
especially them being older when they're
kids there's a little bit more of an
excuse and even when they were in Avatar
they're still discovering it in a unique
way and that was so much fun um this
show I don't know if it has quite the
fun aspect of it but I I don't
necessarily need that if it wants to go
dark and let's go grittier that's fine I
get if anything is trying to be more
adult but don't don't rely on these
other tropes that again we've just seen
a million times so um that's about it
there's a sorry I guess I couldn't go
into too many other too much other
detail but
I guess I still want to see where it
goes it is a good show um I'm hoping it
sort of ties together a little bit more
in it just I want to see it get going
it's like you always get a little hit
there and it's like don't get going get
going if you're not gonna get going
make these characters doing more cool
stuff you know hey let's go back to our
house let's go
bending again or the bending competition
let's go dodge those spinny things like
the leap it's do something else go
somewhere else I got you know you
finally went into this ditch area I
might finally just a different location
guess what it's dark and hard to see
just like a lot of the night scenes it
just mmm it still good animation good
angles but man lets us just mix it up
with it so um that's re bad I hope that
doesn't like I still like the show um I
just want to see it get going so that's
if I Det bout it sorry it's been sort of
scatterbrain here and yeah I'll see you
next episode